[Music]
um I think it's great news I think any
more support for us in general would be
a great helping hand I am planning to go
back to work full-time so any help we
can get to you know help that transition
back to work I think it's really really
hard for working moms as well
celebrating St Patrick's Day today
obviously in this group and it's like
finding that pot of gold at the end of
the rainbow so this actually takes the
pressure off for the cost of living
crisis and everything that's going on
around us parents they're delighted by
the chancellor Jeremy Hunt's
announcement that he's expanding free
child care for working parents in
England to cover all under fives we will
introduce 30 hours of free child care
not just for three and four-year-olds
but for every single child over the age
of nine months at the moment parents in
England can pay up to 14 and a half
thousand pounds a year to get child care
for one and two-year-olds it's expensive
in fact the UK has some of the high
highest child care costs in the world
and that means that many parents decide
not to go back to work because it's just
too costly
but the government wants to change all
that and Jeremy Hunt believes his child
care package will do just that so for
any parents who are moving into work or
want to increase their hours we will pay
the child care costs up front but not
everyone's happy many nurseries in
England say the plans are unworkable and
will leave them out of pocket so what is
the true cost of child care I'm Kimberly
Leonard and this is the Sky News Daily
I'm going to be speaking to two Nursery
owners one who is forced to sell up
because of the rising costs and another
who's deeply concerned about Staffing
levels but first here Sky's political
correspondent Tamara Cohen the
chancellor announced that all children
from age nine months can have 33 hours
if their parents are both working now
because this is a big big expansion it's
not going to happen overnight so all
those people with toddlers who are
really excited
um from next April so in a year's time
there will be 15 free hours for
two-year-olds and then it will be the
following September so September 25 that
the chancellor says the whole policy
will be brought in but of course it all
depends on whether the nurseries and
child minders can provide it and
currently there aren't enough of them so
they need to scale it up significantly
and not only childcare from the age of
nine months but um sound also talking
about wrap around child care for
school-aged children how is that going
to work yeah so all these measures are
really aimed at getting people back into
the workplace who are economically
inactive and we we do know I've done
I've done quite a few reports about this
that high child care costs mean a lot of
women particularly women drop out of the
workforce or cut their hours back
because they simply can't afford the
child care around it and then you do end
up with a sort of lifelong career
penalty there the gender pay Gap opens
up at that stage and many women might
want to stay at home but some just feel
forced to because of financial
considerations so the chancellor also
announced that in addition to money for
early years
um he would put 400 million into making
sure that primary schools offer wrap
around care so breakfast clubs and after
school clubs that go on from 8am till 6
p.m to help working parents so a lot of
schools do that already now but for
those that don't they will get some more
money to set them up parents will still
have to pay for their child to attend
but it's all part of a package of trying
to get more women back into the
workplace so I think the jet in general
parents and providers and
um and those who will be who will be
doing this child care applaud the aim
but there's just real questions
particularly for the early years about
how how it's going to be implemented so
the finances of this are going to be so
key
um the chancellor said it would all cost
four billion pounds I mean I think a lot
of those looking at it will say it will
cost a lot more in the end
we have some of the most expensive child
care in the world don't we this is a big
deal for the parents if you're looking
at it from their side oh absolutely I
think um there's been calls for this
um for some time labor have over the
last few months been saying we need
child care to run from the end of
Parental leave at nine months right up
until children start school because
um yes you get some subsidized hours
when children are free are three years
old but what you're supposed to do in
the interim you know but it's before
it's before that when women are going
back to work that they start cutting
back their hours and then um and then
you end up
um unable to to get back back up to
speed so so there's certainly demand for
this Britain's child care costs are very
high to give you an idea of how high
they are
um there's a report every year by a
charity called Quorum which surveys
local local authorities across the
country and full-time child care now for
a child aged under two is Fourteen and a
half thousand pounds a year so it's a
huge amount and until and while they're
one and two years old you don't get much
back from the government you get to get
the tax back but it's still very very
expensive I think everyone agrees that
there are huge benefits all round for
the workplace for getting women into the
workplace but also for the children
themselves if it is if it is good high
quality child care then it really helps
to
um to narrow the the disadvantaged Gap
so that this children from disadvantaged
backgrounds and can have the same
opportunities
um as as those whose parents can afford
to pay for it so I think everyone agrees
on the benefits but there's just
questions about how quickly this can be
ramped up and whether it the sector who
are seeing you know people who work in
child care do not get paid very much
they work very hard because they don't
get you know school holidays or anything
so how they're going to encourage people
to go and work in these nurseries to set
themselves up as child minders and
that's the bit of the puzzle that we
haven't quite had an answer to yet now
it's all designed to get all to even
allow working parents to get back to
work do we have any stats about how much
of a difference it's going to make so
yesterday the official forecast of the
office for Budget responsibility the obr
which are independent from government
said they reckoned about 60 000 women
could come back back to work or increase
their hours as a result um but of course
it has to be it has to be delivered
first and it will take a few years to do
that and what are labor saying about all
of this uh labor have been saying for a
few months now that child care is going
to be a Battleground issue at the next
election so they've yet to set out their
plans have the government Nick their
policy and therefore you know stolen a
march on them well in a way yes but I
think what will happen now is the
government have announced their plans
and labor will probably announce theirs
later in the year and they now know what
the government are offering so they can
offer something perhaps over and above
that
um so we now have the parties really
really bidding for voters on this issue
issue of child care it must be said on
on the on the question of what what are
the sort of considerations
um the chancellor has offered is talking
about these three hours for working
parents so it's not for everybody it's
for families where both parents are
working at least 16 hours or if it's a
single parent for one parent working 16
hours so it will be good for working
parents but not for those who are
looking for work or studying or unable
to find work and so if you look at the
sort of chart of who will benefit it is
the top best off third of households who
will get most of the money and the
people in the lowest income groups who
will be unable to get it so there is a
social Mobility question there as well
and I wonder whether it when labor
announced their plans they will go for
something that's more Universal so not
just for working parents but for all
parents and I think that could be a
popular offer at the election
the government's four billion pound
investment in child care will
undoubtedly be life-changing for many
parents when it eventually comes into
full effect in 2025 but what does it all
mean for those who are providing the
care this vast expansion of free child
care for all children of working parents
under the age of five has already
prompted warnings from Nursery owners
it's funded but not free and I think a
lot of parents think it's actually free
but the rent that we get off the
government wants the top slice has been
taken off by the local Authority it
falls much much shorter than is needed
by nurseries and child minders to
actually function financially properly
this is Sharon Birch she owned an
award-winning Nursery in Hartlepool for
17 years until earlier this year when
the costs forced her out we can
completely understand that parents will
will be really happy and with receiving
the extra support for for child care
however that needs to be delivered in
the right way for us to be sustainable
in the future this is Steph Barrett
who's a manager of be bright preschool
in Lincolnshire and she feels the same
why is it so expensive if you've got
people who are on minimum wage
and people who are paying huge amounts
of money for this service
what are these overheads that all the
money goes on well these staff wages 75
to 85 percent of your income goals on
staff wages
um then you've got insurance food
resources rent electricity and gas which
is increased massively
with business rates Vehicles if you
provide a vehicle Transport Service
which lots of nurseries do now we've got
um
teachers you've got to pay teachers a
proper word you can't give them a wage
that a lot of Nursery nurses have to
accept so you've got to pay your staff
what they're worth and there's a huge
recruitment Drive the more um a death of
really good quality stuff because people
can go and earn more working in
supermarkets and warehouses than the
carrying child care because the
overheads are so high so the money that
they're actually promising actually only
equates to around 30 Pence per child per
hour so we're already in a deficit of
around uh one pound an hour we're at the
deficit deficit over to the moment so
that 30 Pence is not going to help the
deficit we are already in and you're
there what's going to happen is there's
going to be more pressure on us because
we're going to have to deliver extra
funded hours
so you're running at a loss of a pound
for every child per hour
that's correct yes
um so
um what's happened is
um the government pledged to um increase
the funding rate uh with
um whether the amount of time that went
on and with inflation and what's
happened is that that hasn't been put in
place so we've got for example this year
the national living wage increase is
around nine to ten percent for most of
our staff yet the funding increase was
only three to four percent so there's
already a deficit there so the the money
isn't there the funding has never stayed
quite in line with the cost of living if
you're running at a loss how do you
continue both owners are are taking uh
significantly reduced wage we don't work
at minute we don't receive even minimum
wage and we're trying to ensure that our
staff get paid first before us and which
is obviously having an impact on our own
love we both have mortgages to pay we
both have our own families to support
but we can only do that for so long
um before or the deficit becomes too
much
um and we and we have to close the doors
um that's the reality of it okay Sharon
back to you for this one is the issue
with Staffing the ratio the number of
staff to the number of children the
ratio problem is not a solution because
if you risk staff children to ratios
have you tried looking after five
toddlers one person it is an absolute
difficulty when they're all live wires
they all want to do different things and
if you raise the ratio you're diluting
the quality and diluting the capability
and is it really going to be that safe
and it's just going to put more stress
on the on the team that we've got here
you it's already hard enough to have to
be able to manage four two-year-olds let
alone five two-year-olds well let me let
me just jump in there and ask you
Stephanie if you think one adult can
look after five two-year-olds
no absolutely not and as a parent myself
would I want my two-year-old
um to be in with with four other teals
and one one adult no I wouldn't but it's
that it's it's dangerous and to have
five two-year-olds to one adult Sharon
tell us a bit more about your story
because you owned a nursery in
Hartlepool for 17 years and it was rated
outstanding yep um we achieved very
outstanding we won two national
um industry Awards Nursery World award
three on growth investors on people lots
of Business Awards we really provided a
really massively brilliant service to
our families struggling in an area of
high deprivation parents from all
structures of society but really really
engaged really good service but because
my background is in policing not
childcare and despite having lots of
qualifications I I'm not allowed to
manage my own Nursery so I had to employ
a manager coming out of corvid there
just wasn't the the wage the money's
there to pay a million income and you
can't strip your staff there because
they're the ones looking after your
children and they're the ones that need
to be there so I was the one that was
indispensable really I didn't want to
close the nursery although financially
that's what all the figures said but by
stepping away and actually giving the
nursery away to my manager who was
perfectly capable of running it she's
been paid throughout she can have that
word she can still pay her that pay
herself that wage but by running the
nursery yourself and taking me out of
the equation the nursery can still keep
going
and that was an unfortunate decision I
had to make it was either I go of the
whole Nursery course that must have been
a really really tough decision to make
after 17 years absolutely it was a
difficult decision but in some ways it
was an easy decision I didn't want the
nursery to go we've done so well and I
certainly didn't want to make 34 35
people redundant what do you think the
future looks like for nurseries do you
think they can survive and what is the
solution here well nobody's going to go
into child care it's just so stressful
and so restrictive you're not only have
you got offset in the local Authority
you've got the health and safety
executive and
um Food hygiene and many many other
legal bodies that all come and
inspection you have to be it's so
heavily regulated and you have to be so
highly trained for such a low wage it's
quite Bleak there was over 5000
nurseries closed last year we didn't
want to be one of those statistics we
cannot continue
um offering a child a space on the
government-funded hours for only for
only the cost of a cup of coffee and the
answer I think is to obviously increase
the funding rate that we all receive
um it's very all very well saying that
you're offering the government are
offering free funding but that is not
free it comes at a cost and at the
moment with it being all parents having
the impression that it's free and
they're you know they all have this
entire entitlement to have the free
hours that's then devaluing our role as
early years Educators the children in
our care all receive an early years
education as the primary school students
do in our Secondary School students do
and we should be paid accordingly to
that my staff can get paid more to go
and work in some of the local
supermarkets to us and it's a far less
stressful job for them so I can't I
can't retain the staff and because I
can't physically pay them anymore
because of the funding we receive do you
would you want your child to be you know
a looked after at the cost of a cup of
coffee it's a you know it's an
interesting concept
my thanks to Tamara Cohen Steph Barrett
and Sharon Birch this episode was
produced by Emma Ray Woodhouse and Alex
Eden